نعم نحن لازلنا هنا مع الجمهور المغربي في
استاد التاريخ في استاد اعاده تاريخ في
استاد الثمامه بالدوحه حد يكرر المنتخب
المغربي انجاز 86 ويتاهل متصدرا امام
منتخبين اوروبيين كبيرين كرواتيا وبلجيكا
المنتخب المغربي تصدر هذه المجموعه بكل
جداره عبد الله كسره كل الارقام من كان
يقول ان انتصار المنتخب المغربي امام
بلجيكا صدفه هو يكمم الافواه ويلجم جميع
مشاكل في منتهى المنتخب المغربي بفوز
واستحقاق وسيطره
ومنع المنتخب الكندي من الاحداث اي مفاجاه
اليوم منتخب المغربي اكد على استحقاقه
ويقول لكل المغربيين ولكل العرب مبروكين
مبروكين مبروكين للجميع مبروك للجميع
المنتخب المغربي اليوم مع جمهور الكبير
عبد الله كان في جمهور كبير لم يستطع ايضا
دخول الملعب كانت الاحتفالات ولا هنا جزء
من عندك الجموع الكبيره
[موسيقى]